HBO's Game of Thrones closed down at six
season with arguably one of the greatest
finales in television history and with
one of the most incredible revelations
in the show's run so far oh and in case
you couldn't tell
spoilers ahead
Bran's vision confirms what fans have
long suspected John isn't actually the
bastard son of Ned Stark instead he's
actually Ned's nephew the child of his
sister Lyanna Stark this is huge and
here's why
half Targaryen we didn't get to fully
herewith Liana whispered to Ned just
before she died but it seems likely that
her baby is the son of Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen and this handy infographic
released by HBO a few days after the
finale would seem to confirm this fact
quick refresher the war that made Robert
Baratheon King in the first place
it started when Rhaegar apparently
abducted Roberts wife to be Lyanna stark
but brans vision revealed that lianna
gave birth to baby Jon Snow in the Tower
of joy we still don't know for sure but
it seems like maybe Rhaegar didn't
abduct Liana but simply invited her to
be his lover and she willingly accepted
if true that means Jon is the son of
heirs from two noble houses the Starks
and the Targaryens that gives him a
claim to Winterfell and the Iron Throne
if only brand can give him the scoop on
his lineage Ned Stark's honorable
dishonor Ned Stark had to lie and say
that he sired John out of wedlock just
to protect John's identity that brought
dishonor to his name and made his wife
Catelyn think he'd cheated on her all to
prevent King Robert from discovering the
infant threat to his new hold on the
throne Ned also forced himself to keep
John at a distance to maintain his
bastard status despite him being the
only thing that remained of his beloved
sister don't forget Ned's last words to
John before he set off for the Nights
Watch Starks have manned the wall for
thousands of years
you wanna stop you might have my name
behind my blood thanks Uncle Ned a new
threat to Queen Cersei we all know the
newly crowned Queen Cersei is one of the
worst villains of the series and with no
more children left to appoint as
horrible rulers the likely candidates to
usurp Cersei are Daenerys John or Peter
Baelish but only if you can convince
Sansa Stark to marry him nevertheless
John unknowingly has a legitimate claim
to the crown and if he can prove it he
could March his forces southward take
the pointy chair and stop the invading
White Walkers will he marry Antin Eris
being the son of Rhaegar Targaryen makes
Jon Snow Daenerys his nephew sorry to
everyone hoping for King John to marry
the mother of dragons in the end but
that's his auntie that said incest was
generally acceptable for the Targaryen
but if Jaime and Cersei Lannister
twincest has led to this many problems
throughout the Seven Kingdoms
we don't imagine a happily ever after
love story ending in a shallow gene pool
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what you think
will happen in Game of Thrones next
you